foreign
Jonathan is up first in Salt Lake City
Utah Jonathan how can we help today
hi guys thanks for having me you bet
what's up
so a little background
um I'm a medical provider I work in
Urgent Care
um so obviously I wouldn't be the
college thing and during that process
accumulated a lot of student debt uh the
total damage was three hundred and
twenty thousand dollars whoa
um yeah it was just like MD what was
this what'd you end up with actually
actually a pa
um wow so did you still have the debt
so over the past year I've knocked down
knocked it down to ninety two thousand
dollars nice wow
yeah that's a part of that is uh kind of
the question I've had this side gig the
side business for years and years I
actually went through college teaching
Anatomy on the side and so we had this
little side anatomy lab that I was
working at while in school and it kind
of just put it along and kind of did its
thing for a while I mean it was somewhat
profitable but we decided to go on to
social media I think the end of 2019
beginning of 2020
created a YouTube channel and it just
went nuts after that and so what's
happened is I you know technically I'm
on baby step two still here but this is
taking more and more and more of my time
to the point where I've gone down to
about 20 hours a week
um as in my medical provider job in the
Urgent Care
and there's this constant pull to just
say you know what I need to go off of
the uh and Go full bore into this side
gig I think there's just a lot of fear
on my end as far as how much all right
I'll tell you what we're gonna do George
and I are going to walk you through some
facts
instead of focusing on your fear all
right so how much money are you making
uh off the YouTube channel
oh geez that's so that one's a little
challenging I think because that's part
of the fear because why is it
challenging I mean you can look and see
what you're what's your worst month
what's your best month and what's the
average
um I think the average because I have a
business partner and obviously we have
employees and things like that but my
taxes for last year I think about close
to 300 000. wow that's what you made is
that well yeah you personally made
yeah off of this YouTube business well
that was with the a let's see with my
provider medical provider I I know I
know but I didn't ask you that I want to
know how much you're making what are you
paying yourself off of this YouTube
channel
um well probably around that two to
three hundred a year
um based on uh a little bit comes out
and just mostly draws I don't take much
of a salary every month
we kind of decide me and my business
partner at the end of like each quarter
or the end of each year
um
okay I'm still confused so let's let's
what are you making as a PA right now
what are you making so the PA make about
80 000 just because I'm doing the 20
hours a week okay and so and so now
you're on track to make two or three
hundred thousand give or take a hundred
thousand on YouTube okay so you're
clearly making more on YouTube you are
paying yourself more from your YouTube
channel a good bit more than you are as
a PA true
true well so how much money have you so
so I you can make the move now
you know or you can say I'm gonna stay
in the PA job I'm going to continue to
build the YouTube channel and grow it
clearly the thing is taken off and
that's a serious amount of cash man
um and kudos to you uh yeah so it's
really your call here we want you to pay
off the debt so maybe you stay in the PA
position
and keep double earning there until you
knock out the debt and get through baby
step three and get the emergency fund in
full uh you know three or six months and
then make the move uh but you can make a
case George that he could do it now you
know because you can always go back to
being a PA if for some reason you start
sucking uh with all the YouTube videos
uh YouTube changes its algorithm and all
of a sudden you're making half of that
but even then you're still making 150
Grand a year from YouTube alone and so
once this debt is knocked out your
expenses are way down you've been living
on less than you make clearly to get
this debt knocked out so I like the plan
because you said the fear is coming into
play of sticking with the PA job at 20
hours a week knocking out the debt
getting a fully funded emergency fund of
six months and then you it's not a leap
you're just taking a soft little step
off the dock there onto the boat
yeah okay how's that feel
um it feels pretty good I mean uh I
think my biggest issue was is like I
think I'm like there's growth that can
happen in the YouTube channel because
we're going into other obviously social
media platforms and things like that and
so there's this the battle was always
just should I I can do this faster if I
have 20 more hours that I can just dump
into you know the the job but it's it's
an irrational fear I understand that
it's like people in my life have said
you know you can always go back to being
a PA that's what I just said I literally
just said that so I don't think this is
risky either way
um okay we told you the safe plan George
and I agree on the safer play
um yeah can I ask and I don't want this
to be a big endorsement so if you turn
it into one I'll cut you off but I'm
just curious are you what are you
teaching about Anatomy on YouTube is
that what I'm hearing
yeah you know it's so I we started our
own private cadaver lab because you know
that's a that's a normal thing to do oh
my God so you are working on cadavers on
YouTube and teaching Anatomy so like
people are watching you guys do this
that's what the deal is yeah so like
we'll do a video on like the heart and
how the heart works and we'll show an
actual heart and obviously we'll use
graphics and pictures and stuff like
that it's kind of like the channel to
help anybody learn more about their body
wow that is fantastic very cool
um definitely not want to have a snack
while you're watching that no I was just
gonna say I wouldn't well there's riches
in the niches Ken and so if you ever
think you know what is there yeah you've
never heard that before say that again
there's riches in the niches this guy
this side is in the niche I'm gonna zoom
into this weird Little slice of the
internet making a YouTube channel about
anatomy and it goes way more yeah than
he does in his full-time job wow pretty
cool well I tell you George this is more
evidence
that higher education and education as
we know it is in big trouble people are
going to YouTube learning stuff I mean
it's more interesting it is Jonathan's
teaching it instead of your professor oh
by the way it's free